[Musique]
la diane chanter dans les cours des 15 m
et devant du matin souffler sous l'élan
taire la voix de baudelaire résonne
sourdement cette eau quelconque une
quelconque journée d'hiver à l'heure où
le pari du travail qui se frotte les
yeux empoigne ces outils pour un nouvel
effort
derrière le voile que dans l'asphyxié
des usines une ville énorme grouillante
unis les dernières rumeurs d'une fête au
premier fracas des marteaux paris
monstrueuse merveille surprenant
d'assemblage de pierre de machines
l'idée c'est aussi l'entassement des
siècles et les souvenirs
après baudelaire balzac césar birotteau
la cousine bette monter ce décor les
ruelles les maisons basses humides sont
rongés de salpêtre est clos a appelé
pavés les voies assassine où seuls les
chats sont à l'aise
[Musique]
on sait pour avoir quelque peu voyagé
que ce que le touriste appelle le
pittoresque
c'est généralement la misère
[Musique]
pittoresque que ses courses et passage
ses ruines nous des êtres vivants des
parisiens s'accroche au spectre d'une
ville engloutie
[Musique]
ce que nous avons vu c'est long l'ombre
du 19e siècle qui lentement tourner ses
faces
[Musique]
pour
[Applaudissements]
si le pari futur est à l'état débauche
ces parisiens eux par contre sont là
leur foule nous pressent leur nombre ni
contre 1,8 million d'habitants
aujourd'hui près de 12 millions dans 20
ans si les forces de développement ne
sont pas contrarier
[Musique]
la ville envahies de l'intérieur par ses
propres concitoyens dressent les seuls
remparts capable de la sauver la durée
moyenne de la vie humaine a doublé la
cité répercute l'évidence 350 personnes
nouvelles viennent s'y établir chaque
jour cent vingt-sept mille par an
ajoutons les soixante mille âmes donné
par le simple rapport natalité mortalité
on comprend que le cauchemar la hantise
du nombre soit le meilleur stimulant des
chantiers par ailleurs la concentration
des administrations
l'absence des villes relais le sous
développement des provinces rendent
l'enflure inéluctable l'urbanisme idéal
inscrits dans le ciment la coexistence
du logement et des échanges pour assumer
sa vocation européenne
paris a besoin de grands quartiers
d'affaires moderne d'un équipement qui
lui permet de faire face au présent et à
venir
les travaux de la défense l'opération
maine montparnasse prouve que la machine
est lancée elle en longeant c'est
orgueilleuse archipel architecturaux qui
songe aux 270 mille logements qui n'ont
pas encore l'eau ou 70 milles qui n'ont
pas l'électricité ou 950 milles qui
n'ont ni baignoire ni douches l'hygiène
suppose une bataille incessante
chaque matin une armée de 4000 éboueurs
par faire la toilette début chaque matin
aussi des milliers de concierge sont
astreints à la corvée des poubelles
nauséabondes rempli à ras bord malgré
l'entrée en scène récente de moyens
perfectionner
[Musique]
coût
sur les marchés des sacs en papier
collecte les débris et les femmes encore
que le ballet de bruyère cher à la dune
en afrique conserve un rôle de premier
plan
non
l'entretien les frais de main d'oeuvre
augmente chaque année en dépit de la
récupération que l' usine de brûlage
d'ici assure pour le chauffage urbain il
est nécessaire de pousser plus avant les
techniques parvenir un abaissement des
portes
et
[Musique]
on
le ventre de paris où ce que l'on
appelle ainsi paré féminisme ne cesse
lui non plus de croître et d'embellir le
parisien mangent de moins en moins de
pain consomment de plus en plus de
viande
[Applaudissements]
à noter lavage construit aux abattoirs
de la villette assure une fin
d'existence parfaitement urbaine elle
aussi aux animaux débarquer désherbage
c'est une préfiguration de l'abattoir
ultramoderne qui se substituera aux
installations archaïque à l'époque des
cosmonautes dans un quartier conçu pour
y loger à pied et à cheval les halles
centrales était le dernier rappel des
gigantesques marchés à mangeaille du
moyen-âge rungis les accueillera bientôt
nous devrons dire adieu aux nuits
parfumé d'herbe et de thym à l'odeur de
fraises de cancun et de marjolaine
[Musique]
le parisien est présentement victimes du
gigantisme d'une ville dont il assure la
richesse et l'as rome
paris interdit aux piétons mais que dire
des automobiles
[Musique]
une guérilla incessante et sournoise
oppose les uns aux autres accordant
l'avantagé à une catégorie pour le lui
retirer aussitôt un million cinq cent
mille voitures aujourd'hui 3 millions en
1975 ce problème d'accroissement
continue se pose maintenant en termes de
survie car si la voiture au début
permettait de se déplacer rapidement
d'un point de la ville à un autre elle
devient un corps étranger qui bouchent
les artères qui deux remèdes se change
en mal
à paris la population dispose d'une
voiture pour cinq habitants mais cette
richesse engendre des frustrations et
paradoxalement ralenti ce qu'elle
devrait accélérer
bon an mal an le citadin en est réduit à
passer 20 % de sa vie éveillée dans les
transports soit individuel ou collectif
c'est là un gaspillage de temps et
d'énergie nerveuse dont les marchands de
tranquillisants sont seuls à se réjouir
l'urbanité la maladie nouvelle dénoncée
par les médecins n'est pas
spécifiquement parisienne c'est avant
tout le mal des habitants surmené des
métropoles
[Musique]
l'individu qui vient habiter la ville en
supporter les contraintes en reçoit des
dédommagements d'un côté un monde
organisé police et domestiques
l'eau chaude au robinet et le confort
électroménager de l'autre les feux
rouges
les guichets de banques les panneaux de
stationnement les contraventions les
embouteillages et cette illusion tenace
constamment dénoncé par les faits
cependant croire que l'on a le temps que
l'on a le droit que l'on à la place de
passer
la plus jolie ville du monde quoi qu'on
en dise et de ravissantes surprises qui
nous paierons de tous
[Musique]
on
si le mouvement le charme le prestige de
paris nous dédommage bien les choses
des problèmes matériels eux restent
entiers
[Musique]
oui
savez vous à combien revient d'un
parking comme celui des invalides
[Musique]
un parking comme celui de l'avenue
georges st on ose et 100 g combien coûte
à km le boulevard périphérique 40
millions de nouveaux francs les radiales
qui relieront ce boulevard au centre
reviendront à 60 millions le kilomètre
un simple équipement de carrefour en
fruits rouges postule une facture de 40
mille nouveaux francs et pourtant c'est
le prix qu'il faut payer pour assurer
aux parisiens un minimum de liberté tête
en raison de ses exigences tous les
jours a cru l'automobile soumet la ville
et lui dicte sa loi
de vastes et ouvrages sont nécessaires
elles l'échangeur du pont de sèvres du
boulevard périphérique qui ceinturera
paris un tronçon est déjà terminée
partant de la porte de sèvres passant
par la porte de versailles la cité
universitaire il aboutit à la porte
d'italie
ce que l'on appelait autrefois les
barrières les portes de paris est
devenue un immense chantier les travaux
se poursuivent porte l'italie porte
d'ivry et porte de vitry porte de
bagnolet une antenne routière équipés de
parking se raccordera au boulevard
périphérique par un échangeur sept
réalisations associées à un important
programme de construction de logements
modernes rénovera les quartiers est de
paris
les échangeurs tel celui ci porte de
pantin permettront au trafic automobile
d'entrer et de sortir du boulevard
périphérique ou de le franchir en toute
sécurité
celui de la chapelle raccordera le
périphérique à l'autoroute du nord
[Musique]
la voie express rive droite reliera en
quelques minutes le viaduc d'auteuil au
pont de bercy
jalonnent l'itinéraire en partie déjà
réalisés le long de la berge
voici la maison de la radio le pont des
invalides
les premiers travaux du bourg la reine
[Musique]
la concorde la cité
l'île saint louis et le pont sully dont
la maquette nous montre un aspect
prochain de la voie sur berge adjointe
aux transports de surface les lignes du
métropolitain apporte aux citadins une
garantie d'exactitude du non négligeable
dans une ville où chaque rendez-vous se
gagne contre la main pour rattraper le
siècle on met les wagons sur pneus à la
bastille les piétons sur tapis roulant
au châtelet
[Musique]
on ajoute un wagon aura et pour ce faire
on est contraint d'allonger les qu'est
ce qui explique les travaux de la
station vavin et cette image de l'église
saint-germain-des-prés prise du fond
d'un chantier
diderot qui habitait en face ne
reconnaît plus son quartier
même préoccupation place de l'étoile où
les travaux du métro express qui reliera
la défense la bastille sont poussés au
maximum des possibilités
en même temps on étudie la maquette du
futur métro suspendues
symbole de la metropolis de demain
[Applaudissements]
tout ce qui roule vol glisse ou cours
contribue à rapprocher le citadin du
monde d'espacé de verdure il est en
train de lentement reconquérir en dehors
de la zone des affaires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si sa vie quotidienne il fait en
pittoresque il découvrira par contre
qu'une personnalité collective n'est
dans les grands ans les habitants ce
groupe organise des foyers de jeunes
forment des associations culturelles et
sportives leurs enfants font de bonheur
leur expérience de groupe
toutes classes sociales confondues ici
se situe exactement la charnière entre
hier et demain
élevé dans les notions d'hier l'homme
découvre les règles collectives de
l'avenir l'eau l'air l'espace le vent
les éléments naturels dont il était
sevré reviennent vers lui et aussi ce
que saint-exupéry appelait l'espace de
l'esprit le silence
[Musique]
pourtant si quelques uns sont heureux
dès aujourd'hui les problèmes subsistent
pour le plus grand nombre il faut des
hôpitaux autant que des autoroutes
celui ci est le premier mise en
construction depuis 30 ans
[Musique]
il faut les garderies d'enfants il faut
des lycées des écoles
les hommes de demain le devoir d'être
meilleur mieux instruits la génération
qui leur a donné vous un fils doit être
plus intelligente son père c'est la loi
du progrès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
demain c'est déjà aujourd'hui dès à
présent il faut mieux se loger mieux
circuler mieux respirer dans la ville
il faut en même temps préserver les
pierres qui sortent vivante du passé
[Musique]
le moindre recoin de ses palais la
moindre de ses maçonnerie ont vu l'ombre
d'un prince ou d'un roi dans cette
florence secrète accessible aux gamins
de la rue du roi de sicile de la rue
vieille du temple de la rue des
francs-bourgeois couperin hugo madame de
sévigné nicolas flamel la reine margot
nerval kallos trop avaient leurs
occupations lors flânerie leur amour
[Musique]
ce n'est pourtant pas vers la nuit
somptueuse et plein de passer que cris
ses souvenirs le coeur de ville
le coeur du vieux paris des carrosses et
les mystères bas trop faiblement
aujourd'hui pour irriguer le corps
immense qui bouge qui travaillent paris
qui vit séparée que l'on ne sculpte et
que l'on soigne paris ville d'où ces
féroces éternelle est menacée c'est
cette lumière qui monte de la terre des
chantiers des monuments restaurer des
arbres en bourgeons c'est aussi la boîte
baudelaire qui revient à nous pour finir
paris change mais rien dans sa
mélancolie n'a bougé baleine péchabou
d'âge bloc vieux faubourg tout pour moi
devient allégories et mes chers
souvenirs sont plus lourds que les rock
[Musique]